Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier, and welcome back to Resident Evil.
Now, we just got done killing the dude
The father, Daddy is now dead,
but I don't know if he's gonna stay dead forever so
I can't help but think, once more, that this virus
or fungus, or whatever it may be...
I'm leaning toward fungus,
is funded by the Umbrella Corporation maybe in the vein
that they submitted this girl into their care
because the father said
that she chose
"Him"
to be her father.
and she already has chosen Mia to be her mother
because she calls Mia "mommy",
and that's evident in the video she made, and also in the drawings that were made.
So
it seems like this little girl is choosing a new family
and maybe the current members of the family aren't gonna be too happy about that
because they
they like this power. And also, Grandma's here. So, hi, Grandma
how you doin' there?
Should I shoot you in the back of the head? I can't even aim. Oh, there we go!
Alright, I can't even aim at Grandma
Alright, Grandma
Yeah, you're looking good these days, sorry I might have killed your son
not sure about that
you do your thing
I'll do my thing
Yeesh.
She getting a bit more active than she has in the past
she's a bit more shaky.
'Cause I seem to distinctly remember she being
uuh way too calm
for her own good.
But, either way...
Ookay. Alright then, that's weird.
Okay, we got the dog relief, so we're gonna put that on there. Shabooski!
I guess it's just open now.
Am I free to go??
Alright, sorry, I'm just taking it in a little bit, because
this doesn't look like anything I saw on the way in,
but this might be the front of the house, or the back of the house. I'm not 100% sure.
But, man! This place is a lot bigger than I thought it would be.
and quite possibly a lot bigger than it needed to be
But, who am I to judge? Alright, let's scavenge for items here.
"Cause we're going to need a lot. I am completely out of bullets.
I've only got two normal bullets left, they're not even the high powered variety.
Because I spent pretty much all I had on killing Daddy.
And, so, that's not going to be very good for me. I've got a lot materials.
I'm gonna make a habit of keeping them on me, so that when I get chem I can just instantly put that away.
I'm gonna put that there, because why not?
But, hopefully, at some point, I get more storage.
Sorry! Hah, you dang crow (great accent, Mark).
Alright, anything here that I need? No?
Whoa, okay, never mind.
Thought that I heard something. God damn it.
This would be a good point for psycho stimulants, but I left that in my items box.
Because, I'm willing to bet there's a lot of itty bitty items here that I might need.
Oh! Those are supplements. Why would I need supplements. "Pills that affect the nervous system. Can't be used as is, make them into medicine first."
Oh, that can be made into psychostimulants!
Oh, and Neuro Rounds. "Ammo for Grenade Launcher. Contains a powerful poison that affects the nervous system"?!
Uh
I don't even-- I don't even know if these creatures have a nervous system.
Okay, so this need some sort of red and blue key.
Someone was getting a little technical here and even put a car battery on this
Well, okay, I dunno who's technical like that. Maybe Lucas is...
Oh, that's. That's lovely. That's lovely that is...
Alright
I wonder if Lucas stays in this trailer here.
I dunno, but let's find out.
Hello~
Oh boy... Don't mind me barging in!
OH! It's another save point!  OH GOOD, oh okay, alright then!
Time to go through everything then (Shakes in disgust) god. I'm getting the heebie jeebies...
Being out here.
And I don't know, woah a broken handgun.
Well what good is that gonna do me.
But it could be repaired with a hand kit.
Oh, it might be a more powerful handgun.
If I find a repair kit I might be able to make that (Oh really mark?) but I'll put it away for now.
And, I'll put this away too cause I doubt I need this.
And then uh... then maybe that'll be a more powerful handgun. Which will mean just, baseline, I'll have more stuff.
What is this?
Steroids; Increase max health...indefinitely?!?!
Woah, Stabilizer. Reloading speed increases indefinitely.
What???
(Sudden realization in progress...) Oh! OH! Oh my god! Coins! That's why I was getting the ancient coins!
It was a monetary system to be able to get those things!
Oh shit
Woah, oh, and it's the whole family.
"It's too late for them."
Oh, okay, Alright
Oh wait! This isn't Lucas' trailer! This is Zoe's
You think maybe?
ooh, what is that?
Magnum, a lot of kickback, but a lot of stopping power.
oh I want that. ooh I want that.
okay, and then there's another-
I don't have another tape, but
there's another one of those.
So I think I have around
six total coins at the moment
I mean the health would be nice,
but I seem to be doing okay.
"Maybe it's Zoe's"
Maybe I shouldn't be looking at it then!
And anyway, that just confirms my suspicion
that is- this is indeed Zoe's trailer.
So, let me just make one more glance around
for anything that I might neeeed.
Doesn't look like it, I think I got it all,
What is this? Here we go:
"My body's feeling weirder and weirder
Soon I'll become like mom and dad.
It's all her fault.
Should I run?
No I can't, I'm dead if she finds out.
That woman she was with, Mia
she knows something.
If I had the serum I could cure myself.
I have to find out more."
huh.
"My body's feeling weird- If I had the serum I could cure myself"
That's bizarre.
oh, and some kind of inscription there.
okay, so let's move on,
we've been hanging around a little bit too long here.
um, but this is fascinating
and I've got six coins!
I could get the magnum
if I just find three more coins,
but I don't know if I'm going to be able to find them soon
or even in this episode, but
*Phone rings*
(mumbling) Alrighty then,
well alright then, well just answer the phone
Hello?
(Zoe) You made it.
(Mark) Yes you did.
(Zoe) You're the first I've ever seen make it this far.
(Ethan) So what is it you need me to do?
(Ethan) Is it gonna help me get out of here?
(Zoe) Yes. Now listen carefully Ethan,
(Zoe) My Family and I...
(Zoe) Our bodies are contaminated.
(Mark) I've noticed.
(Zoe) I can't leave the property unless I get it out.
(Zoe) And the same goes for Mia.
(Ethan) Is there a way to get it out
(Zoe) We need the Serum.
(Mark) huh
(Zoe)It should clear whatever this stuff is outta the body
(Zoe) as long as you're not too far gone.
(Mark) uh huh, okay.
(Ethan) Alright, so where is it?
(Zoe) If I knew where one was, I'd already be long gone
(Zoe) but I have a feeling my mom has hidden some-
(Zoe) -inside the old house somewhere.
(Mark) Hmm.
(Ethan) So if we get this thing,
(Ethan) I can help Mia and we can get out of here?
(Zoe) Right... and so can I.
(Zoe) The old house is near the water, you can't miss it.
(Ethan) Alright.
*Zoe Sighs*
(Zoe) I just hope you can handle my mother.
(Ethan) Your Mother?
(Zoe) Be careful. They'll be lookin' for ya.
*Zoe hangs up*
(Mark) Yup, okay.
So I'm the only one that they've seen get this far
or at least, Zoe has seen get this far.
So what does that mean?
And considering those messages are in Zoe's place-
- I'm assuming Zoe wrote them.
So that must mean that's Zoe.
She''s infected and she wants to get out
I can't guarentee-
that she's not gonna betray me at some point,
and just be selfish,
and look out for herself, but-
I have to at least take so- ooooh fuck.
ah, I WAS SCARED BY A PLANT.
I WAS SCARED BY A LEAF
yep I was indeed, okay.
everybody laugh at me please
but either way, I can't be guaranteed -
that she's going to be so 100% nice about all of this.
"Locked from the other side" Is that where I came in?
no, nah, that's different.
okay.
Alright let's go, the only seh the only way
it seems i can go is over here
so I'm gonna follow this
path. Kinda wanted to hold
off for at least a little bit but here we go
oh no
I'm gonna take care of momma
So a- and i can also assume
that this family is already too far
gone, but that is the infection
spreading through their body. It's like
--  Oh this is where the video
was, this is where Mia's video was
oh shit, so
its like its taking over their body
They are enjoying it because
They have effective immortality, BUT
That doesn't mean it's good-
Their not in control as much as they THINK, they are
And thats usually how it works out
Yes please~
*buzzing sounds* WhoA what the fuck-
EUGHWWWW
LUghwWWH
Alright thats fine, i guess-
Almost as good as bullets
*breath* So as it spreads to their body,
It takes over more and more and thats what revealed-
When-
*Long pause*
Daddy- Got heavly damaged-
Like the thing inside of it was actually dying
It- IT's able to recover but nothing is able to recov-
*loud buzzing* (markiplier oh no face)
I'MM A BRAAAAVE BOYYY
EEEEH
hOly shit fuck-
oH okay-
BAM BITCH fuck off
What the fuck was THAT?
She- ooooh nO you don't
yOu don't exist FUCK YOU
jEezems
That was the fUcking biggest bug i've ever seen
*Loud creaking door*
Egh
oH- i see you
Spotted yaa
Are you gonna fall down-
(and) Become a monster?
Probably
Jeez
How do these people live like this??
LIke seriously how does anybody live like this?
oh fuck
Eugh i got a bad feeling abou- ohhh
That's a pulsating sack of something-
I mean, i've seen great many pulsating sacks in my day
But that is-
*More loud buzzing*
wHooOA thats not go- AH FucK off
fuck off!(2x) fuck
Fuck you(3x)fUCk- Fuck oFF
aH fucking shit
*markimoo girl scream*
*Door creaks*
JeeZsUMs
Alright SURE- i'll just fire into the crowd of buhgs
Well that doesn't do anybody any good
Okay, so that's,
What that probably is,
That probably just means that i can't go through there
now I recall, in Mia's video, there was some sort of
What looked like it might be a flamethrower (Ooooh)
So, I'm imagining that I'm not gonna be able to go
through here, cuz it's like a hornets
nest, but lemme just see if there's any
supplementary-- aAhHhHHHHauuHAhHH ok not gonna go in there 0-0
Well that sucks >:(
So there's gotta be like a flamethrower type deal
that I can get through here.
This can.. is only *laughs*
This is what I can only assume is the "old house"
Man, I love what you've done with the place :D
Ugh
Oh fuck it's another one.
Ehhhhhh.. No No
and SPIDERS TOO!?!?!
GOD
"She's upstairs, don't go up"!
ok
Why is Mama so scary?
(idk you tell me, maybe EVERYTHING WE'VE SEEN HER DONE but just a thought :) )
*calmer* "She's upstairs, don't go up"
and someone scratched out "don't"
UUUUUHHGG
*buzzing* YEIYIYIYIYIYIYI
*buzzing intensifies* AYIYIYIYI
AYE FUCKING
*sassy markimoo* AYE YI YI YI
YI YI YI YI YI FUCK
FUCKING FUCK
Jezus Christ
Well that was NOT worth it
maybe
omg this whole place is infested
oh man
This place is a god damn nightmare and I'm wasting too many things
on this. Solid fuel-
Okay, so that- that does confirm my suspition that
that there might be a FUCKING FLAMETHROWER here-
-weird hissing noise-
fucking why?!
The fuck was that?
-awkward pause-
...okay
eeeeuuuuuugh....
I don't want to touch that
What is this- what?
I can't use...
Can I jimmy it open?
Ah fuck
locked drawer over there
That definitely wouldn't have the, uh
it wouldn't have the flamethrower in there
that's for sure- oh God another nest
ffffuck
-rustling-
Hey hey WHOA buddy boo
whoa buddy boo whoa buddy
WHOA buddy
BAM BITCH!
okay, alright then
wasting a lot of shit on this
wasting a lot of stuff that I don't need  to waste
heAAYFUCKING
FUCKING FUCKING FUCK
fuck you nnnOOOOO
aahhh fucking FUCK
I should have just-
what I should have done is I should have realized
that I'm following the path that Mia went
so obviously
I would be going back here
and I would know what I need to do because
the flamethrower was obviously through here
God I'm an idiot
oh boy- kid's room, contaminated room, detention room
OOoooh that sounds so
FUUUUUUUUNNN :D
OH I'm going to have such a good time!
Fuck this shit..
Ugh, bugs
Eugh
Okay
I'll open this, nothing in here
another brassiere
okay... so whatever the thing for the shadow is not there anymore
buuuut
that doesn't mean I can't get it again-
I do not recall there being THIS many spiders
And also WHY in the HELL- oh
-creaking-
what was THAT
Jesus
Okay I think I see the thing
I didn't miss it
I, uh,  definitely see it, but
I just wanted to
check everything out- so THAT is...
DEFinitely...
The thing I need
So- OH it's part of the thing I need
It's a burner grip
Burner fuel
So solid fuel with chem fluid
will be able to make the burner
Sssoooo...
Is this part of what I needed?
"It looks like something that can be combined with something else"
So there's definitely another piece of the puzzle here
and hopefully I can get to a storage  box soon because
because I am completely out of space here
I might as well use my shotgun because
at least I'll be able to free up a space once all my shotgun ammo is done
Oooo this looks bad...
what is that-
Is that a backpack?!
OOOH!
PLEASE tell me that's a backpack!
OH PLEASE-
YES!
FINALLY!!!
FUCKING YES BABY
-dance time-
FUCK yeah! Oh FUCK yes- how much more space?
Eehhh four more slots, that's good enough I guess
I heard that
Nobody better sneaking on me when I'm in this place...
This seems like a safe space
and I want to make sure that my safe space is properly safe.
I don't know what the benefit of breaking those is, by the way.
'kay whatever, alright
So now that I got that
I have four more spaces which means that
I will definitely be able to hold on to these
Hold on to my first aid, I need a little more of that
Uh, let's get an ammo row going
Okay, this is the ammo row, this is the supply row
This is a spare part, I don't have the other piece of it yet
so I can always come back for it
-deep breath- Alright...
So I don't necessarily need this right now.
But I've got inventory space, so why not? Why not? There's no harm...
So we're in good shape!
We've got even more space, which I was hoping for
now that I got a backpack
which means I won't be so stressed
and pressed for supplies all the time, and I'll be able to carry more on me
But we've still got to go back because
we need to know where the second half of this flamethrower is-
whoa...
That's scary as shit...
We need the other half of this flamethrower
and I don't know where it could be...
I don't know where it would be...
But what I'm gonna do is I have psycho-stimulants!
I forgot about that
I have psycho-stimulants, which means I can use that
Right now
To be able to... look for shit
And looking for shit is exactly what I need to do right now
Alright
Show me the money!
Really? Nothing? Okay there's something over there... Ah! Okay!
Well OBVIOUSLY something's over there because
that's where the gawdamn THING was!
ooOOP but I see something over there
Something over there- ooo! There's stuff everywhere
Oh hello!
-glass crashing- Oay-
-louder shattering glass-
AYY FUCKING- WHOA wait- whoa whoa
Fucking nOPE!
Oooooh fuck you f-
OOOooooohhh fuck you...
Whoa
Fuck you oh fuck you okay
Wow that's- that was useless
But what is this?
What are you...?
Why can't I pick you up?
Oh THERE we go, okay then
There's something there, and then there's something over here
Oh there's...
There's things in here-
WHOA MAN I missed everything!
Holy shit!
Whoa what's out there?
Ooohhh there's something on the other side over here ooOOOOHHH okay
Jesus Christ I missed EVERYTHING!
Holy SHIT
There's something over here?!
OH MY GOD
Oh, tackle box
is there wayurms?
OOO Lockpick! I'll take that
Psycho-stimulants! Exactly what I needed! Okay.
Good GOD those are SO useful!
And also good GOD is it possibe to find anything in this place?!
Okay so I can't go through that door, that is a trap..
Uuuhhh maybe...
Maybe I could combine the burner grit with just the... burner fuel?
-failed clicking attempts at combination-
Not that, okay it needs something else
But there's something over here, but if I recall...
There's another obstacle in the way
Ho boy that's not...
There's a tackle box, but-
oooh that's bad
HuuuuuuuaaaaaaAAAH
I'm not going to be able to get to that am I?
Fuck...
UUUH Fuck!
So there IS one place I COULD go
It's just I'm gonna get BIT to SHIT when I do it
But I'm gonna go for it
IIII'm a bRAVE BOY!!!
AaAaAaAaAaAaAaAa
...okay? I guess we're okay
Well fuck YOU
and fuck YOU
Alright fuck you guys
OH I guess I'm okay, alright
Is there anything in here that I need?
uUH oh
ah-
OH burner nozzle! Perfect!
Okay so I just combine
IwoouoyUURCombine
this with this...
And there we go!
Holy shit!
Homemade flamethrothupthuru-
FLAMEthrower crafted from junk! Needs fuel to burn
Well that is good,but now I am suddenly
in an odd predicament of being completely full on my shit
Uuuuhhhh SHIT
Alright WHATEVER it-it's fine
but at least I got the flamethrower now, and I should be able to burn what I need to burn
YEP. THAT WORKS. Yep I trust this with my life.
Alright...
I trust that with my wife.
I trust that with my knife
I trust that with my... uh... -muttering to self-
Alright, let's test it out!
Let's test this bad boy OUT, uh?
Let's test it out-
aTOOSH
Oop need to be closer...
aTOOSH!
-hissing sound-
OOOOOAAAAAAAAoooohhhh
burn it with FIRE!!!
Ooh HELL YEAH
OH HELL YEAH!
Wuuuh?
AH- no no no no no no NOOONO
Okay... Well! That is...
effective!
Okay- wuUUHYUHFUCK
AAAH
So it's got a lot of layers...
It's like an ogre or an onion...
(Really Mark?)
My God you need to do a lot for that thing...
Well fuck that shit
OH
Now that the center has been exposed
I can probably shoot-
-hissing-
OH fuck
AH!FUCKIN-
UAAAAAFUCKFUCKFUCK fuck a duAYAYAY
FUCK
FUCK OFF
FUCKOFF with you
JESUS Christ...
Well THAT wasted a lot of FUCKING FUEL
-pwoof!-
Okay, there we go, but at least I've got some chem in here
I don't have enough space but I know where to go to GET space
Jesus- OKAY well that was largely ineffective
But at least now I know how to use it properly
You blast the nest and then you shoot the nest once it's exposed
That's what you gotta do, those are the steps that you need to take
and now I have some stuff that I need to drop off
I've got chem waiting for me
I should be able to make more flamethrower fuel if I need it, but
I think I'll be able to conserve with what I got right now.
Okay, we do this first...
OKAY! So I got what I need and I know where I need to go-
OH boy, alright
Enough lazing about, running into bugs nonstop
Let's get what I need and get the FUCK out of here
because I don't need to use NEARLY as much flame fuel as I have been
Which is good- how am I doing on health?
I'm doing alright, I can survive another hit.
I've got two chem storage right here,
I know I'm going to use the strong one to make strong bullets
make STRAHNG bullets
blump
And then use the other one to make more flame fuel
blahm
Okay, and now I've got that, I've got extra flame fuel
I've got sturANGH bullets
And then I've got one health thing and one lockpick, okay
It's NOT a lot
but it's what I've got
now let's do this...
hoo boy, here we go!
hoo boy...
Where are you guys at?
Ah fuck right there, RIGHT there right there
AaarrrIgotcha-
nopenope
nope nope
NO
-fwoooosh-
There we go, toast that up...
Ah
c'mon
-fwoyoyoyoyooosh-
Alright, got that, and then boink
boink
BOINK!
-pissed off bugs hissing-
OH boy...
Oh! There we go! And it's gone -ooo boy just a few left...
Okay!
Well got that done
HOOO! Alright then!
Oh there's another one in here
I forgot about that...
ah fu-
ooOOOO!
Wait a minute...
WHOA, HELLO
Maybe I don't need to kill that one because I can go around it...
Okay! Alright, I'll go down here! I'll see what's up!
Let's see what's going on
What's going on down here
Huh?
Any suspicious activity?
HUH?!
Ethan! Help!
Ok, I don't know if I want to.
Like, I'm a little conflicted.
I-I don't know what I should do, what I wanna do.
It's a little mixed-up right now.
I can't see a damn thing.
So uhh....
Yeah I don't know, I don't know if I should actually come help you, because Mia seems like an almost lost cause.
But I guess I'm a dedicated husband and I want to save her.
So let's do that.
I don't see any other items here.
Lucas seems like a little piece of shit, but I should be able to take care of him okay.
His hand seems to have grown back okay too.
Unless he just got it re-attachted like ''moi''.
Then again, honestly, who knowes?
Ok.
So now that I got that, I can go around the back way.
*Shouting*
Is there anything I need to drop off?
Why do I have a crank again?
I guess it's a multipurpose crank to be able
to use it whenever I need to.
Oh, a note:
Zoe, you tried to sneak up to the second floor again,
didn't you?!
Did you think I wouldn't notice?!?!
Even after what happened to Eveline, you just keep talking about some strange medicine.
And what are you planning to do with my altar?
You better keep those sticky fingers off of it!
Nobody touches my sacred altar!
You think your father and I are idiots?!
You spoiled pathetic child...
I wish you'd never been born.
Unforgivably pathetic yet always looking down on us
and trying to leave our home!
After everything we've done for you...
Pathetic, pathetic, pathetic, pathetic...
If you ever even touch my altar, I'll slice off your chest
and serve it up as pot roast...
Well, that's... that's awfully nice.
I'm assuming that's from mother,
who is a sweetheart.
I'm just gonna make more first aid,
because, I seem to be running low on that
I thought I was gonna be better about it
with all the blocking.
So I need like the crow key?
Is that what I need? The crow key?
Where the fuck am I gonna get the crow key?
Unless from mother, I suppose.
But I don't know if I want to waste all the ammo if it's just gonna be a fruitless face-off against momma.
I'm... I'm guessing that ending's gonna be a bit more cinematic than what I've been seeing here.
But, OK. I've got a number of things...
... that are useful to me.
I've got...
... as long as momma's not hanging around here.
I've got... a flamethrower.
I've got a crank, which could be used for
something else... somewhere in the house.
And I've got a lockpick for...
some fuckin' reason.
Whoa... aye aye aye aye aye aye aye aye aye...
Aye aye aye!
No.
Stop it.
Stop existing.
Momma... is that you, momma?
Ew...
*deranged laugh*
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, fu... Oh, fuck... Ew... Ewww...
Ewwww...
I need to burn this thing.
Oh, fuck. That is fucking bizarre.
Lady, you got a lot of problems.
Oh Hi!
Okay, good!
Alright, then! You're such a loving and caring mother.
Gonna go the long way round again
Ring-a-round the momma
Yeesh
What? a lady!
What a lady!
Daddy should be a proud man!
Good good good, keep going that way
Good, good, good... keep going that way...
Good good good good keep going that way.
ah fucking! WHOA
AH! FUCKING!
Ah! Fucking! WHOA!
Ah fucking, woah
WOOOAH!
OOH okay shes really  blind
Oh, okay! She's REALLY blind...
OH OK!
SHE'S REALLY BLIND!
OK, but ah-
OK, but...
Fuck you
Fuck you.
fuck you
fuck you,
fuck you-you-oh
fuck you
Fuck you.
fuck you, you- oh fuck I'm out
fuck you,
... you... oh, fuck, I'm out.
Fuck, im out
oh fuck im out
fuuuuck you! *lots of fucks given!*
Fuuuck youuu.
fuck you.
FUck you alright
Alright but, I can use the crank
Alright. I can use the crank... here
I can use the crank here
here,
And be able to crank the yank open to that thing
and then be able to crank the yank open to that thing.
and then be able to crank the yank
open to that thing.
And then go over there wherever the hell that is
And then be able to go over there, where ever the hell that is and
And then go over there,
wherever the hell that is and get what I need to get.
and get what i need to get
get what i need to get. Ohh im out of here baby.
Ooooh, I'm outta here, baby.
OOOh im outta here baby~!
I don't know why I trust this.
i dunno why i trust this
Okay first aid that's good.
OK, first aid, that's good.
That's good, oooh hullo
Hello!
Hellooo.
Oh what the hell is this, what the
What the hell is this?
What the h3ll is this?? Oh the crowkey!
What the fuck?
fuck. Oh the crow key!
Oh, the crow key!
GREAT!
Great!
A+ for me!
i like me a crowkey!
I like me a crow key.
awh fUck i dont have enough space it-
Oh, fuck, I don't have enough space for the uh...
Oh fuck I don't have enough space for a ahh
awh fck oh i can just
Fu... oh I can just burn off a little bit.
Oh I can just burn off a little bit
burn off a little bit
Toot... toot... toot... toot.
Toot Toot Toot
And then reload that, and that shit'll give me everything that I need.
Then reload that and that should
and then reload that
give me everything that i need
should give me everything i neeed
Man
I think they gave me the extra inventory because there's no way I would even be able to play with anything else.
good thing they gave me the extra inventory
there is no way I would even be able to play with anything else
Because there is no way i d be able to play with anything else
Alright gimme that. Gimme that please, thankyou.
Now, gimme that. Gimme that, please.
Thank you.
give me that please thank you
Alright, just one more and I've got the better gun.
Alright, just one more and then I've got the better gun
just one more and ive got the better gun
I dont know if I uh i um uh I'm assuming it uses the same bullets or anything but.
Assuming it just uses the same bullets
Who knows honestly
Who knows honestly.
At least they were stocked up on toilet paper and bags of shit
At least they are stocked up on toilet paper and bags of shit.
Alright
So carry my way back through
Alright carry my way back through
Might as well reload with the good ammo.
Might as well reload with good ammo
Alright so this uh- this this ammo has got some pep to it
This-this ammo has got some pep to it
It's got a lot of pep so i gotta be very careful
It's got a lot of pep, so I gotta be very careful about it some imma use the shotgun
about it so i gotta use the shotgun,
the SHOUTgun. Alright
The Shout-gun
Alright, she she can't tell, she doesn't know.
She can't tell She doesn't know
Momma doesn't know.
Okay carrying on
Alright.
So I take the crow key, I go upstairs,
which Momma probably isn't going to like me going up in her private area
But atleast I'll be able to go upstairs to where the punishment room and the contaminated room are
HEY! FUCKING,
WHAT THE FUCK!
HOLY SHIT.
Ow.
Fuck you man!
Ohhhh nooooo
Ohhhh noooo
Ahhhh bye Momma!
Hey Momma you gonna come down here with me or what?
Ah lets not. Oh boy.
Come on, no no no no
Just gotta snap these guys up with my knife.
Conserve some ammo
Yeah, I'm pretty sure I can acutally
Snap and snap bap
crackle and pop.
There we go alright.
Snap, snap, snip-pity snip
Ah fuck, ow, ow, ow
Come on!
Come on, come on, come on
Uh oh.
Oh that's, that's a thing.
There we go
Hey huh, how's that?
Oh don't come down here.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no Momma
Momma.
I do not like you, imma leave you down here.
Okay.
I don't know what's happening to her.
Oh boy.
Okay.
Woah.
What the fucking fuck
Uhh..
Okay Momma you...
You have fun.
Alright.
Gonna go now.
Thank you.
Okay.
Oh fuck.
Alright, carrying on.
Use the crow key.
Jesus.
What a fucked up key system.
Woahhh.
Hanging babies...
Hanging babies.
Oh hanging babies.
OH hanging babies.
Okay.
Alright, yeah
Target acquired
What the fuck?
Alright then..
Ohhhhh huh huh huh huh huh huh huuh
Huh huh huh huhh
Ohh
Eee
Ahh
Regarding the series serum
the following items be able synthesize serum.
1. D Series cranial nerve
D. Series Peripheral nerve
Oh
Ohh.
Okay then...
What the fuck is this
Its like some kind of medical kit,
probably again provided again by Umbrella corporation
but their is something to this...child in here
this corpse of a child.
That may be like the progenitor of all of this? I don't know
Maybe this has a lot more importance than we think it does.
Cause it seems innocuous.
I mean it seems innocuous with the dangling baby dolls but,
There's probably alot more to this thing, right in front of us, than we think it is.
But anyway.
So there's nothing else there.
There is a baseball bat right there.
I would love to pick that up.
Would love to have a better melee weapon than just a
Oh fuck.
Alright, hi Zoe what do you want?
What do you want Zoe?
Got your shit.
Wait, is she actually gonna be at the trailer?
Probably not.
But that's so weird. A D.Series arm and a D. Series head
Oh well and D.Series Cranial nerve and a D.Series peripheral nerve
Oh but that's so weird.
That's so weird.
So I need a head, an arm and a then a injector needle. Okay that is bizzare.
Lets find out what else is up here
Before we go on too further.
Yeesh, hello.
Alright then.
Ohhhh.
This,
this voodoo doll.
This is one of the things that use to be hanging in the demo,
in the little room.
The little alcove.
Hi!
Oh you look friendly.
Piano.
Anything else in here? Ooh hello.
October 11th. My ears have been ringing all day and I haven't been able to sleep since the child showed up.
It's like Zoe says; There's something strange about the child,
and the woman she brought with her.
I'm seeing things, hearing things can't stop feeling nauseous.
I went to see the doctor in town and he gave me an X-Ray. What's happening to me?
The child gave me a present.
I put the present in he secret room right at the back of the second floor, whre nobody will find it.
That arm is a sign of the childs trust.
That arm will lead us to happiness.
And anyone who corrupts that happiness...
I won't allow them to live.
Alright then.
That is fucking bizzare.
So there's some deeper secret here, thats assembled from all of these different pieces of the puzzle here.
There's something going on here... Uhhh.
What is this thing? It looks like a dead rat.
Whatever it is...
I dont know why I had to pick that up to look at it
I'll just shove it in my face and get a good whiff of the smells coming off of that bad boy.
But uh, I did just that.
What the fuck is that?
What the fuck is that?? There's something there.
Oh it's the teeter-totter thing
Ohhhhh...
That's what she meant by her light
So this needs to be balanced with another light, before it's going to unlock.
Is that the case? Yeahhh that is the case. Okay.
But I don't have the light, the scale and the door seem to be connected.
You'd think that I'd just be able to weight it properly and it would work but,
but no. Ohh Antique coin! That means nine!
Oh that's good.
Okay that's good, I can get the other gun.
Yes, no.
Maybe so.
I don't know.
But I found out more about where the arm is, so maybe i can go back to the trailer now to tell Zoe about it.
If Zoe is there,, which i have a funny feeling she's not.
Probably just means Zoe's gonna be calling me on the phone.
Should i be so lucky.
Momma?
Mom?
Woahhhhhhh Momma!
Oh Momma you grew!
Oh Momma I never knew
Oh Momma, I don't want to go down there.
Oh I don't want to go down there but apparently i need that light.
So what I'm gonna do, is I'm gonna go outside.
And try and go back track a bit and imma try and go to the
go to the,
trailer. Woooof
Yeesh.
Alright, loading a bit.
Oh, load, load, load.
Alrighty then.
So what I'm gonna do is go back to the trailer,
I'm gonna get the Magnium, I'll have a more powerful gun, hopefully that's what that means.
And then everything will be hunkey dorey.
Ohh.
Hello, Zoe? You in here?
Sorry about touching your bra
Your unmentionables.
You in here, you in here?
Zoe?
Nope.
Zoe's not in here.
Alrighty then.
Mkay, alright then. But I have a total of nine coins.
And that means, that I should,
be able to, no not that,
that means that I should be able to get this thing.
Right here.
Maginum, a lot of kick back, but alot of stopping power. So if i put these in here
Shink, oh god I gotta do this one at a time.
And shubooski
And there we have it.
44 Maginum
Which oh god, its a bigger gun.
Has a lot of bite, but a lot of recoil too. So...
If I'm not mistaking that uses standard handgun ammo.
Which I don't have a lot of right now oddly enough but,
it uses standard handgun ammo
And supposedly
It's gonna help me on my way.
So how do i get ammo out of the other handgun?
Standard power handgun designed mainly for ease of use.
Is there a way to like empty this out? I don't know why there's gotta be like...
Where's there gotta be anything about it
Right so whatever
It, either way this is going in storage.
I dont think  I can pull the bullets out of it but at least i have that.
So now..
I'm doing pretty good.
Oddly enough I'm doing pretty damn good, I know where the serum is and i know where to go to get to mamma
I gotta go down, i dont wanna go down but i gotta go down.
So...
Im gonna build up my braveness and then go for that. I've got my new handgun
I don't have bullets for it but I gotta hand gun.
Before i move on here.
What I''m gonna do is , I'm actually gonna go actually im gonna start right here.
I'm gonna  use some pyschostimulants to be able to
find some more items because I'm sure, I'm sure that I've left some like right here, oh there's a hole bunch
Hello, what are you?
What are you, well uh, Antique coin that's good.
You?
Jesus there is so much stuff here.
What are you? Oh a lock pick okay got you, that's good.
Herbs, ahh fuck now I'm full. What the fuck dude!
Well that wasn't supposed to happen but holy shit, I left stuff right out here.
Boyo Boyo, oh fuck there is another thing right there! Oh fuck you.
Alright and what are you?
Jee-sums. Chem Fluid right there in front of my goddamned face. Didn't see it.
Item there, what's under here? Ohh something in the back okay.
Jee-sums there is so many things, okay I'll toss this in there, Imma toss this for now, toss this for now, I'll come back for this, come back for this
Alright whatever, gotta go gotta go running out of time, running our of time
time, time, time, time
Okay got that
There was something around the back.
Back down here
Shotgun shells
That's good, that's good, that's good. Go in the house, in the house, in the house in the house house house house house house
Reload this one, ahh yeah that looks powerful.
Reload it. Oh no. OH NO. Oh No, It takes, it takes like magnium ammo are you serious.
Oh no, well I gotta put that in storage and bring out the hand gun again. Whoopsie doopsis.
Fucking bullshit
Why does it gotta be dfferent ammo.
Alright so now that I did that, what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna make another loop of the upstairs area because i know for a fact that I probably missed
a whole bunch of shit,
that I should have seen the first time around but i didn't because I am an idiot.
I'm gonna try this again
What did I? Oh my god are you kidding me i missed this box the hole time.
Oh my god and you
What the fucking fuck.And their is something over there. Oh my god I'm an idiot.
Oh no.
Oh no I'm dumb.
Okay, so now I've got a whole bunch of useful things.
And I found another coin of all things, uhm- I found a lot of herbs, I found alot of gun powder, I found just oodles and oodles of stuff. I'm gonna keep the gun powder on me.
Uh, I found seperating agent, I don't even know what that's gonna really do for me.
But! I've got everything that I need
I've got three med kits, I've got gun powder for when I find more chem.
I've got a little bit of burner fuel which I know I'm gonna neeeed.
I've got shotgun shells out the wazoo!
I've got everything that I need to be able to face of with momma-
Who seems to be a little bit different than I remember her being!
So either way, thank you everybody so much for watching, I uh- I'm eagerly anticipating going down into the darkness.
...all of which I hate very much.
But! We'll get to that in the next episode so, thank you everybody so much for watching!
And as always:
I will see YOU.. in the next video!
BUH-BYE! (<3)